walk here him to this video playing step
by step from Bulgaria I've played him
seven times I've got slide minor score
minus one let's see in the news oh I
don't really recall the games that have
played against him yeah okay I'll let
let's do the loser Rick again I have
varied a bit in recent games but I know
this line quite well as I did used in
Maya my book project some five here no I
think it's castles first yeah let's go
sobs first yeah now White has a choice
III g3 e 4 B 4 B 3 yeah that's a one of
the main moves III okay yeah that's an
interesting strategy he's going for the
f4 moose and the long run keeping the
porn on III I am going for a quick home
now he's switching back to to an e4 set
up interesting
a five intends to play a four at the
right mode blocking in the queenside
okay does not does not do anything to
prevent that it's not clear that he
needs to but simply is not reacting to
the idea I came now many ideas can play
97 c5a for immediately there are many
young possible lines kid this is an
interesting timing because now check I
get in c5 and close close the position
AB
okay so he's he does not mind to to shut
down the the queenside completely okay
let's see how to play it like to get I'd
like to get f5 and obviously this would
be a good good break however I expect
him to play something like bishop moves
rugae one or still at four this is not
not out of this world that he would
still play a form okay I'm preparing a
five trying for that if I remember him
correctly is playing a very
straightforward manner so I force
something that can be expected ok it's
not doing that but now i get an f5 right
there is no I'm Bishop f5 maybe then
hmm yeah the bishop is looking very
silly there but I cannot f5 Bishop eight
597 you will take f5 this is not very
convenient
I have a totally weird idea i'll try
this I'm I mean it looks like totally
bonkers but I'm playing it anyway Bishop
a 598 the kind of move where you getting
laughed at but ok it's not trying to
fuel it which which would be would be
six okay yeah now i don't i don't mind
that too much the night the night there
okay it I need rook e8 badly getting
getting the rook traded
I wonder Edric I wouldn't I wonder but
look a 7 luque a drug be seven maybe you
can do that maybe queen d8 could be a
defense Queen d8 rook takes this night
XD five this discovery now probably
something like that needs to be done I
don't see another way to to defend it
but it should be okay i believe rugby
695 rook moves and then i have not f4 or
possibly am ok now rook be aid is a
trade yep I'm bit down on time but not
not hopelessly behind like it sometimes
happens ok yeah that's that's good it's
a good idea opening is opening up the
position on the on the King side while
Mike weenis is not supporting in any way
time warning hmm cam takes takes the end
94 but I don't really see what else I
for was strong okay that's 90 for coming
I can maybe I can get in queen nia to e7
it's a bit passive but maybe still still
have a valid valid defense of try and
this was not good that I allowed this F
for this this type of thing happening
yeah maybe this idea with the nitre c 7
8 9 a-8 that was a bit bit that two
original ok yeah I think that I can
still defend this with the King 97
maybe I'm wrong answer possible of
course
Kim G Force probably winning yes check
check now I have points myself but
connected passes are usually very tough
to stop hmm but my points are are still
very dangerous check that was that
wasn't a good idea rly a deck or they're
thinking no I don't I don't know it just
promotes as stupid very very stupid I'm
not sure maybe I really had some chances
that he will get the pawns I'm not sure
I mean maybe I'm lost but i am not i'm
not totally sure y'all care the computer
says i'm completely losing even here but
while this is a draw this is a draw i
forgot about i heard about this patently
yeah he I just draw no one nothing
nothing terrible happening yeah it was
it's a it's a typical situation where
the other side right here I mean okay
it's a deserved loss I was worse most of
the game but he really does not need to
play any good moves because he will win
on time I have no chance whatsoever to
make the time control so he can play any
nonsense and still win
and yeah this is one of the arguments in
favor of a decent time control anyway
let's let's look at this I think maybe
this idea with 98 was a bit bit too bit
too original for its own good the main
problem however was the timing that was
happening here they went here and then
fyf was really strong we could have done
that right away so on I didn't really
play this plate as well I guess this
this idea to put the night on a eight is
is really not not very good yeah I just
need to play it more conservatively
where various ways to do that one idea
for example is after this to play the
move Bishop g4 because it looks a bit
weird to trade off the yeah nominally
bad bishop on YouTube but this is not
really a bad bishop because what has
this huge advantage in space the best
move was probably f3 keeping pieces on
the ball and then i go here with a
decent enough position i believe i have
Roo k8 in case he tries to play on the a
file and I have this idea to get counter
plane if he tries this I need to make
sure that I get something on only five
or I stop a five can even go 98 and f6
then Bishop c8 9075 it's a very solid
position really it's not very active but
but but solid yeah Bishop g4 was much
better this is this idea was a bit more
ambitious but it really had problems
with F for which are underestimated
around here f4 is just wrong it's very
tough to defend
after that look at this it's it's just
it's just very passive until you let me
out again later which is in a way
understandable because you you don't
really have any pressure with white you
see we went on time until had some
chances with the both points but ok
didn't materialize ok thanks for
watching